j'ai non seulement toutes les
vaccinations obligatoires mais à chaque
fois que dans un pays il faut une
vaccination même pour le confort sain
pour être sûr je le fais j'ai confiance
dans votre lit
j'ai confiance dans l'oeuf dans le
vaccin et vous vous avez vous faire
vacciner
non pour l'instant non mais je voudrais
dire d'ailleurs que non pourquoi pas
parce que d'abord je suis pas du tout
dans les publics cibles 07 60 j'aimerais
si vous voulez que y'a un truc qui me
fascine dans cette affaire c'est que
c'est une maladie et on parle pas de
traitement et prévention dans cette
affaire c'est quand même incroyable
c'est un truc c'est arrivé tout de suite
on s'est mis tête baissée sur les
mesures confinement les restrictions les
couvre-feux ça a été partout dans le
monde entier non non ça car elles
montrent ici n'ont ainsi pas m'agrandir
vous allez voir il ya eu d'autres débats
oui vous allez à taïwan
il ya huit morts depuis le début ils ont
dit nous on soigne les gens vous avez
plein de médecins en france sont obligés
de soigner un peu en clandestinité voyez
on refile de l'hydroxyte look in de
l'hiver mais quoi en fait tout ça c'est
quand même ça ça me fascine sur le reste
moi je suis pas pour que deux d'enrayer
la trier pas le vaccin
le vaccin fait partie de la stratégie
mais ça peut pas être que ça mais moi je
pense que derrière il ya eu beaucoup
d'idéologie ou parce que moi j'entendais
monsieur vers ans il ya six mois à dire
le vaccin russe fonctionne pas et c'est
ça c'était leur expulsion
maintenant le voit 80 ans maintenant ils
fonctionnent voilà après on nous a dit
il faut passer absolument par l'union
européenne cherchez pas plus loin le
problème logistique c'est que l'union
peine ça fonctionne pas quel manque de
7,2 cette chose qui est l'agilité dans
la mondialisation que seule une est à
100 des messieurs philippe au royaume
uni est ce que vous êtes allé dans un
service de médecine parce que si vous
expliquer aux gens dans un service de
médecine qui ne sont pas des pressions
les patients de la colite je pense
qu'ils vont avoir un mémoire de l'eau y
aller vous allez retrouver sur la
réanimation vous êtes je parle d'un
pourquoi n'y a dorénavant je parle
d'avant s'ils voulaient les gens ce que
dit raul depuis début et plein d'autres
et on dit ce collectif traitement à
distance et brimé pialat plein cyrielle
la colchicine il situe pasteur de lille
qui est en train de travailler sur une
vous êtes trop et qui pour le
l'englobant sam davies et scassa
maréchalat c'est pas la réanimation la
rénovation il ya des supers progrès
parlé mais là je parle d'avant c'est à
dire pour éviter que le quand vous êtes
vous avez des petits symptômes ça
devienne une forme grave et vous soyez
hospitalisé
c'est là où taiwan l'extrême orient et
ça ils ont beaucoup bossé ils ont
beaucoup soigner et nous on sait un plan
embarquer un truc soit en vous assigne à
résidence à la maison et on ferme les
restaurants et tout le reste soit et
puis en même temps on fait le ont fait
le vaccin philippot juste deux petites
secondes
vous voyez bien qu'il ya deux axes il ya
la vaccination d'un côté et puis bien
sûr il ya des gens qui essaient de
soigner et d'essayer de trouver les
médicaments qui pourront soigner
alors aujourd'hui s'il y avait le remède
miracle et si on avait tout les rockies
assuré entendre et toutes les assurances
bien sûr qu'ils le feraient je ne crois
pas qu'il y avait des gens très sérieux
en france a donné pour aller vraiment
guide et on n'a pas envie de soigner les
gens sur qui soignerait avec une
molécule et ses deux filles ne rapporte
rien à ce que le seul médicament qui a
raconté mais c'est l'avenir seuls
médicaments qu un moment à une
autorisation de mise sur le marché par
l'union européenne le premier fin juin
c'était le rem définir alors que des
scientifiques très sérieux vous disais
déjà que c'était inutile et way dont
gérard et moi qui les premiers
la france fer de france c'est la france
qui l'a retirée en premier la deux et la
s'envoyer des mails à tous les médecins
pourront aussi la justice en général
deux là sont très troublés pour quelque
chose
il ya quelque chose qui va préférer
pelli pour résumer surtout je voulais
m'arrêter sur ce point vous avez soulevé
la ya quelques instants il est 21h30 ça
qu'on en direct vous êtes en train de
dire que pour des raisons économiques
il y a des médecins il y a un
gouvernement qui ne soignerait pas les
gens et qui sortirait pas peut-être des
médicaments qui seraient susceptibles de
soigner contre la copie 19 parce que ce
médicament et ces médicaments ne
rapporterait pas assez d'argent il n'y a
même pas je les reprends exactement
l'argumentation que donnera le
complotisme alaphilippe où il ya des
essais cliniques zot cinq ans il ya des
essais cliniques qui sont financés faut
savoir comment ça fonctionne les essais
cliniques sont financées par l'industrie
pharmaceutique
tu sont des entreprises privées qui
veulent faire des bénéfices rémunérer
leurs actionnaires on peut même pas leur
en vouloir à la limite sauf
qu'évidemment il s'intéresse à faire du
fric mais à côté de ça il ya parfois ce
qu'on appelle l'école de la réalisation
des vieilles molécules hydroxy puis
roecklin hiver médecine star et raul
t'explique ils sont très nombreux à
l'expliquer que là ya pas de financement
pour faire à recherches sur ces
médicaments parce que l'industrie
pharmaceutique n'est pas intéressé et il
dit
l'état devrait prendre le relais ce que
vous ne faites pas changé
financé par le public sur l'hydroxyde
chloroquine non si ça n'a jamais c'est
jusqu'au bout et ça n'a jamais été fait
dans les bacs et sur scène c'est à dire
voter non vous avez vu des roxy
chloroquine sur des moribonds de
communication mais je connais très bien
le sujet mal à me tenir une ag dit vous
avez vous avez testé cette molécule sur
des gens moribond or il fallait la
tester au début de la maladie exact mais
bien que si les sept éditions
non c'est parce qu'on est le sable et
c'est la stricte vérité et ce sont des
questions de pognon n'ayant pas tous en
même temps vous allez dans la technique
alors ce que vous faites c'est de la
politique en fait vous êtes en train de
faire un racolage électoral parce que
vous avez compris qu'ils avaient
effectivement une grande souffrance dans
le pays et des doutes et des hellions
mais même ça y est vous dites ça à
chaque fois public qu'un gouvernement
que des députés que des élus laissent
mourir des gens parce qu'il décide de ne
pas les soigner c'est ce que vous
insinuez bon des raisons économiques
donc quand on pense ça le la république
j'entends le chan de l'état si je vais
vous dire là la preuve en est
vous même vous disiez qu'il fallait
absolument mettre des masques maintenant
vous dites quand vous faites vos manifs
dans la rue comme samedi qu'il faut pu
mettre des masques tout et son contraire
parce que vous avez une niche électorale
et vous surfez sur cette oeuvre
souffrances je comprends parce que lui
il est victime de cette crise et peut
avoir des doutes mais que vous utilisiez
ça pourtant votre base politique c'est
vraiment répugnant